This is the real deal.
Whoa.
This is the Jimi
Hendrix of hip hop.
I keep on feeling
older and older
today, just so you guys now.
[music playing]
Earlier, a guy came
in with an ancient coin
from the Roman Empire.
He's asking $150,000 for this.
So I called in my
buddy Dave, and he'll
let me know if I should
beware the Ides of March.
DAVE: When you told me you had a
coin with two daggers and a cap
on it, I ran down here.
RICK: It's like literally
a Game of Thrones
when this was going on.
I mean, everybody
was vying for power.
DAVE: It all boils
down to this coin.
This is Brutus celebrating the
fact that he murdered Julius
Caesar on the Ides of March.
OK, so the big question,
what do you think it's worth?
DAVE: Can I take a
closer look at it?
Absolutely.
Thank you.
[music playing]
This is the real deal.
RICK: OK.
DAVE: I think a collector
would be very happy to pay
about $125,000 for the coin.
Thanks, man.
DAVE: Best of luck.
Congratulations.
- Thank you.
RICK: I agree with Dave.
It's an incredible coin.
It's like, uber, uber cool.
And I would give
you $100,000 for it.
I could come
down maybe to 140.
RICK: I have to set it off.
I have to get it capsulated.
If I give you 110,000, I know
I will at least break even.
I've got to have
more than that.
110's it.
I don't think I
can go below 140.
If you change
your mind or have
really bad luck while you're
in town, come back and see me.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
RICK: OK, so we have
the headless horseman.
[laughter]
CUSTOMER: No.
Drum roll.
Whoa.
So, is this George
Washington's too?
MAN 1: It is.
It's a three-piece suit
that he acquired some time
in the mid 18th century.
RICK: I'm just like, in awe.
If I could go back and
have a cup of coffee
with just about anybody history,
it would probably be this guy.
MAN 1: You just don't
see a piece of Americana
like that is very often.
RICK: Does it have
a price on it?
MAN 2: I wouldn't sell
for less than $3 million.
I'm going to go
think and contemplate
about this for a little bit.
Can we meet up later?
- Absolutely.
- I'm back.
You're back.
Good to see you.
RICK: I've been offered items in
the millions of dollars before,
but I've never really
considered them until now.
The suit-- you asked
for $3 million,
but what's the best you can do?
1.5?
No.
I appreciate your
offer, but it's really
a major part of my collection.
RICK: How about $2 million?
The best price--
absolute best price
would be 2.5 million.
RICK: OK, and you're
firm with that?
Absolutely firm with that.
I mean, OK, well I
guess the suit's out then.
I'll talk to you soon, man.
I didn't get the suit,
but you know what?
It didn't fit me anyway.
I'm at a high end car
store here in Las Vegas,
and I'm looking at the
1996 BMW that Tupac
was shot in over 20 years ago.
Warwick's saying the car is
worth right around $200,000,
but he's not a car guy.
So I still have a few other
questions, some calling
in Bill, my car expert.
BILL: This is an interesting
piece of history.
We're talking about, it's one
car that signifies so much
in pop culture that took place.
What happened to this
car changed history, Rick.
BILL: To bring it up
to your day and age,
this is the Jimi
Hendrix of hip hop.
I keep on feeling
older and older
today, just so you guys know.
My problem is, it's
a little weird.
This was a car a celebrity got
shot and died a few days later.
So in the car world, there's
the driveability factor.
You can own a piece of
history and actually drive it,
and it really won't
devalue it so much.
But this car, because of
the connection to a crime
and a murder and all that
stuff, establishing that value
is the tough part.
I think the right place, at the
right auction, this car, half
a million to a million bucks.
Thanks man.
All right.
If Rick can come to a
deal and buy this car,
this is hands down the coolest
thing we've ever purchased.
It's definitely the
closest thing we've
ever had a chance to purchase.
RICK: How much do
you want for the car?
We're actually
asking $1.5 million.
Whoa.
MAN 3: It's a big number.
Yeah.
A lot more than I'm
willing to pay for it,
but I really appreciate it.
- No problem.
Thank you very much.
CHUMLEE: I can't believe that.
Tupac.